but you know I looked at healthcare I
looked at financial services I looked at
agribusiness you know AG and what was
striking in all of those from just sort
of a cursory some research that I did
you know over the last couple years is
they all the same architecture they all
poured data they all don't share it
laterally and they all are extracting
capital from it for the benefit of their
shareholders not for the benefit of
society that if we just let the data
flow in an environment that is regulated
not by either a you know oligarchic
company or by the government per se but
by us with a environment of trust safety
security privacy built in the things
that could happen would be extraordinary
and so I've been writing a series of
pieces with examples of those right you
have this great image of a bunch of
valves that you write control and write
write if to researchers more data get
rate for that right and it's so people
often obsess and right now they are
because people are so as we were
discussing earlier people are so sort of
woke to the power of data right your
privacy is imperiled you're not getting
paid if you're not getting paid or if
you're not paying you're the product
right everyone sort of woke to the power
of data so there's a lot of obsession on
well my data should be worth something I
should get paid I think that's the wrong
thing to pay attention to it's not
payment its value and how much value
could we unleash for society if what
could be known is knowable
[Music]